I call AZD0120 the sniper CAR-T.
This is one of the CAR-Ts that I honestly was so scared of when we first started the
trials because I didn't know what was going to happen.
They're manufacturing so fast.
They actually encourage not doing bridging if patients aren't just rip-roaring disease.
And it really scared me because, again, every time I get up here, I talk about how much
bridging is important for toxicity.
And at least for me, the patients that have been on have done so well, and they haven't
had any side effects.
And I thought they didn't respond then.
I was like, OK, it didn't work.
And then all of a sudden, they're in CRs and a year or longer out and doing amazingly.
So again, I call it the sniper CAR-T, which I think is pretty fantastic.
So again, we know that there's unmet needs.
And how can we improve CAR-T?
I guess the big question for me and what I'm going to hear from my panel and even Dr.
Garfall, who's actually done some of the CD19 BCMA work way, way back in the day, the
original one, is CD19 really what we're going after?
I don't know, right?
I know there's some cells that look like they are pre-myeloma cells, stem cells.
But what I really think makes this CAR different is the way it's manufactured and actually
the type of CAR-Ts that we're getting into our patients.
Again, with CAR-T cell therapy in general, when I get a product, I actually don't know
what I'm giving my patient that day, right?
That's the biggest unknown.
And so it matters.
I really do think it matters.
And maybe, again, because these are not going to be in culture for very long, I don't know
how long, and they are more T-cell, central memory cells.
Maybe that's why they act the way they do.
So, okay.
So, again, manufacturing, they do see more T-stem cell memory cells.
They're less exhausted phenotype.
These are younger, more potent cells.
Again, not keeping them out of the body for as long.
It does really change those markers of both efficacy, but also maybe toxicity as well.
And then this is the late-line data that we have the most follow-up for from China.
And this is their, again, relapsed refractory patients.
So, 93% overall response rate, 89.6% VGPR or better, and their duration of response was
38 months.
So, again, this was mostly patients in China.
We know that in the past, we used to think, oh, they don't have as many options.
But now, most of those studies that Gurbaksh talked about, those are actually done in China
because they can make their own cars, and each hospital has their own way of doing 10
trials at a time.
So, I take this data actually very seriously, and it looks really, really exciting.
And then the U.S., they actually started just a year ago, but Phase 1B2 trial in relapsed
refractory myeloma.
Again, this was 23 patients that was presented at ASTCT, I believe, ASH and ASTCT.
They're hoping to get to 80 patients soon.
It was more than three prior lines of therapy.
And, of course, patients could not have prior BCMA therapy.
And, again, overall response rate, 96%.
That CR rate or better, 78.3%.
And days to respond, exact 28 days.
So, again, pretty impressive.
And then toxicity or MRD level data that we have.
Again, this is a small number of patients, but 94% for those who are evaluable, and then
100% for those who are older patients.
So, again, the side effect profile being so well tolerated, not having to worry about
the manufacturing for very long, I think is really, really important.
And then no bridging therapy.
Again, no other car will I say that about.
But this one, I do believe that for the majority of patients, because we get these cells within
two weeks.
It still takes about 28 days on a trial to get this into the patient.
But, again, we get the cells so quickly that we haven't had to have bridging therapy.
And those patients still do really well without major toxicity.
So, again, no grade four or higher infections, no dose limiting toxicities, and 35% of their
patients were outpatient because of this.
So, again, pretty impressive in my opinion.
So, again, I think it's a fantastic car.
I think it's different because of the way it's manufactured.
Maybe not the CD19.
But, again, maybe it's a little bit of both.
But, again...
I really want to hear what everybody else on the panel thinks.